i'll say this and here's the big part
because i know for a lot of guys at home
they're still trying to get their sex
life figured out so they may not deal
with this but
when you have
a woman in your life
and or multiple women in your lives and
they really love you
they start to sabotage you
just a little bit
explain
a little bit
well i'm trying to be nice we're on
rich's channel i got to make it disney
for him
a little bit but you know explain
because i'm not sure we'll pass the 30
minute mark go ahead no i'm just i'm
just [ __ ] talking to people who always
talk [ __ ] about me in the comments
section later
um no
but no
like when you're okay so you're in a
relationship with a girl right and she
really loves you
her perception of you she her love for
you she thinks like all other women see
you the same way
and so she got women have this scarcity
mindset right
and so what they do
is they start to give you that extra
scoop of rice they start to tell you
you don't need to like what you're
saying like try to flatten you up a
little bit they treat you like an idiot
they get you fat yeah yeah yeah they
tell you you you and honestly how much
honestly that's part of the data through
a thousand concessions that i wrote
about in that book right right but you
in order to get beta ties you actually
need the attention of a woman first yeah
a lot of these guys don't have right
and so you know they they have nothing
so they're like okay well i i can only
beat my dick six times a day i'm gonna
go like learn to code now and like make
payback you know x pay and then sell it
when it becomes paypal and now i'm gonna
go to you know the rockets and in space
and all that for for elon's situation
right
um
jeff bezos same way right he like just
was sitting there i mean look these guys
were all super unattractive before they
got money as well right everybody misses
out on elon like was literally bald
before he got the hair transplant and
sorted himself out uh bezos the before
and after billion everything went viral
with him right because he got money and
money increases the quality of your life
you get better but yeah i'm going to
grab that picture of the before and
after because that's a really good point
so do the elon musk one as well the hair
transplant yeah yeah hold on a second
and then so what i'm trying to say is
this too right
so in regards to these girls he has
jacked up a little bit there oh he's
definitely got on trt for sure yeah yes
they they will derail you
because they already feel like okay well
he's too successful like if he gets more
money he's gonna replace me right
and look at this dork look at this
picture here compared to this guy on the
right
okay
you got to give the guy some credit for
this though right yeah i mean he has he
has yoked up a little bit let's listen
that's service layer because now pull up
the picture of [ __ ] uh there's the
old picture of elon musk you know from
the paypal days with peter thiel right
right yeah there he's got the hair
transplant with the hair training
put that guy's picture like we should
make fake accounts of elon musk like
from that picture and put it on like
tinder and see how many
look at this picture here of uh
of the google founders it looks like a
freaking profile picture for grindr or
something
but you know kind of like we'll study
girls will actively sabotage you right
when i started like you know getting
some serious success with my youtube
channel and on like my courses and
everything yeah miss mld was like like
throwing temper tantrums in the middle
of launches and stuff because like
subconsciously she's like this guy gets
more money he's gonna [ __ ] leave me
and
women are a constant source of drama and
headaches and the more
you have them around
troy you know what i'm talking about
when you're juggling like three four
girls you got them on on the rotation
you know dude i got these girls in my
life right now there's a civil war a
silent civil war going on
about
who gets true man
who gets this place in the background
[Music]
leaving their hair pins around leaving
shampoo this and that constant like a
little cold civil war against the other
girls and i gotta like i gotta deal with
that in the middle of the whole thing
right it does derail you also like
honestly how motivated are you after you
bang two hot girls in the same day
you're like one i'm gonna lay down and
like play ghost of tsushima and like me
i'll
have a slice of pizza today too right
because you're just like i like every
time i'm the only reason i want to get
ultra rich and successful
is for women nine times out of ten most
guys right they like rich do you like
aspire to be like an ultra billionaire
and and
super
god now no because you have a good life
you have a good sex life and you're
you're totally kosher like these guys
they don't so they become like so
focused and thinking that this is the
only way to solve their problems to an
extent i think also they're a little bit
off they're a little bit psychopaths too
like
you know after you
after you make honestly uh adjusting for
inflation now but i would say
after you make 250 000 a year as a guy
us dollars it's pretty much all the same
like it's like now you're like okay now
i buy hoodies for a thousand yeah
there's been studies on this i think
anything after about 80 or 75 000 like
usd now it doesn't really change your
happiness i mean it just gives you
access to buy cooler [ __ ] i mean just
your toys get more expensive yeah yeah
yep
it's funny isn't it though how there's
the
societal
sort of meme that's gone around for that
for centuries of uh you know behind
every great man is a strong woman
because it seems to me it seems to me
that the the opposite is true really i
mean and no disrespect to the people
involved but i i think all the
girlfriends i've had have probably
sabotaged me more than anything else
really i mean i can't i can't think of
any i can't think of any that's really
gone out to support me and to really
help me to get where i wanted to get to
think about it right like dude these
girls let me tell you the level of
psychopathy i'm dealing with okay
these girls will go
through
my instagram likes and be like i saw
this girl she liked your photo four
times
who is such and such i'm like [ __ ] what
are you doing like why aren't you
studying nfts or investing in crypto
like what are you doing stalking the
likes like the 300 400 plus likes on my
instagram she wants to make sure you're
not moving your resources and attention
to another woman it's evolutionary right
right right that's what you're saying
women get jealous for a completely
different reason than men get jealous
and guys still you're that one girl i
had on the podcast three weeks ago
when you're when you're a super rich guy
or excuse me when you're a super beta
guy you have no attention
none of these girls do you're happy if a
girl even acknowledges your existence
you know what i mean they don't have to
deal with this troy you've dealt with it
right how many how many times have you
been sleeping trolling girls gone
through your phone gone through drawers
whose hair is this whose hair is this
i'm like i don't know what do you mean
dude they look at like fingerprints on
like glass shower doors and mirrors you
know i'll go through your garbage yeah
i'll be looking at a wine glass i that's
not my call that's not my lipstick
i'm just like listen here [ __ ]
csi like what are you doing like calm
down
especially
well i think on some level of
consciousness like women understand like
it whether you are have the potential
for success or you already are
successful
um there is that
women are going to make guard guys for a
different reason than men will make
guard women like men tend to like brian
you know this is like this you know
research has shown that like guys get
jealous if uh if there's infidelity like
if a woman bangs uh another guy outside
of the marriage or whatever
um
that guys are more that that's more of
like an egregious sin to guys because
men are more invested in paternity
whereas when a guy goes and he cheats on
his wife or something it's not it's not
so much the sex act as it is are you in
love with her is there an emotional
connection because it's it's the it's
it's f it's fomo right it's fear missing
out it's it's the idea that this oh no
my lifestyle is going to change my my
long-term security is going to change
because again women only only have a
very brief window in their in their
history 18 and 28 thereabouts where they
can attract and you know be arousing and
get the attention of high value guys
that they want to lock down the rest of
their lives from like 30 until they're
80 or 90 that's going to be spent
trying to secure long-term security and
so when when they mix emotion and they
lead with emotion when they mix a motion
into that into the investment that
they've made in that guy they realize i
won't be able to get as high a quality
guy as this dude again
if i have to if i'm put out back into
the sexual marketplace now of course
there's social conventions that convince
women otherwise but that's the fear and
that's why women get jealous and they
get they make guard according to those
standards as opposed to guys going i
don't want anybody banging my girl and i
do want to clarify this too because a
lot of guys listen to this and you'll
think you're just they think you're just
talking about money you're not it's not
just about resources remember for a girl
getting married that's a status flex
that first divorce now has become a
status blex which is [ __ ] up but yeah
just losing a man to a younger woman
makes you look really bad to your peer
group
that's the thing that terrifies women
yeah so it's not just so much like how
can i check out to get paid no if she
checks out and she ends up being a worse
person at the end that matters more
that's why they hate losing out to these
younger girls cause like oh you couldn't
even keep your man
you